Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and today I want to talk about everyone's
favourite super-baby, Jack-Jack, and explain
and rank his seventeen powers.
If you're new here, I do regular Pixar and
superhero videos plus giveaways.
To enter my latest giveaway, make sure you're
a subscriber, watch my video and let me know
your top three Jack-Jack powers.
Spoilers ahead for Jack-Jack's scenes, so
take care if you haven't seen Incredibles
2 yet and remember you can add this video
to your watch-later playlist.
We see this very briefly in Incredibles 2
when Jack-Jack sneezes.
After Mr Incredible discovers Jack-Jack's
powers for the first time, we see a brief
lightning effect around the super-powered
baby suggesting he can summon electricity.
In fact, it reminds me a bit of Thor's lightning
powers in the MCU.
After Syndrome kidnapped Jack-Jack in the
first movie, the baby transformed into metal,
dragging the villain down and throwing him
off balance.
Jack-Jack's levitation powers are a fun spectacle
we've seen in the short Jack-Jack Attack and
Incredibles 2, and it's something he appears
to be able to control quite well.
Associated with this power is his ability
to reverse gravity selectively.
For example, in the short, while Jack-Jack
hangs upside down on the ceiling, he maintains
his position but allows the milk from his
bottle to fall onto Kari.
When manifesting his powers, Jack-Jack displays
various degrees of super-strength, durability
and resistance.
During the racoon fight, he physically wrestles,
kicks, and smacks the creature across the
yard, and he also picks up and throws garden
furniture with ease.
In Jack-Jack Attack, he was able to chew his
way through a wooden playpen.
There wasn't any sign of wood left over either,
suggesting Jack-Jack's body can even cope
with digesting organic matter like wood.
His skin is also pretty damage-resistant because
he can withstand fighting with the racoon
and even turning himself on fire.
And that ability to burst into flames is pretty
cool and what he touches can catch fire too.
He used this power against Syndrome in the
first movie, but it's something that often
seems to be triggered by emotion.
It'd definitely be good to see him learn to
harness the ability more and even potentially
throw fireballs.
Another cool power Jack-Jack has in Incredibles
2 is the ability to rocket jump or blast off
and that often seems to be brought on by a
sneeze.
Jack-Jack has a sort of elasticity, similar
to his mother, where he can stretch his body,
for example, when he's attacked by the raccoon.
And this could well be an important part of
his seeming invulnerability.
There's an interesting moment in the Incredibile
when, after escaping from the hynoptised Supers
at the house, the Parr children are feeling
unsure about how to go forward.
Jack-Jack levitates, rotates and at the same
time performs a weird reality distortion effect
that warps and wobbles the space inside the
car.
This reminds the kids that they have a secret
weapon: their highly super-powered baby brother
and that kick-starts them into action.
Seeing Jack-Jack create multiple copies of
himself is pretty awesome.
This is a useful skill against an opponent,
and we see this when Jack-Jack attacks the
racoon, and it reminds me somewhat of Agent
Smith from The Matrix.
Jack-Jack also self-multiplies at Edna's house
and while he's there we also get to see his
power of mimicry.
He can not only make himself look like the
feisty fashion designer, but he can also imitate
her physical expressions.
Jack-Jack used his ability to shapeshift into
a demon to ferociously good effect against
Syndrome.
As the infant transforms he gets red skin,
longer nails and sharper teeth, plus his muscles
expand giving him increased strength and manoeuvrability
which he uses to pull out Syndrome's hair
and attack his rocket boots.
The sequel also shows Jack-Jack transforming
into a demon on multiple occasions and suggests
this power is often triggered when the toddler
gets angry, for example, when he's denied
a cookie.
It's a pretty funny moment in Incredibles
2 when Jack-Jack grows into a giant baby,
bursting out of an air vent where he and his
siblings are hiding.
He also then smashes and runs through a series
of metal walls in a moment that reminded me
of Juggernaut in X-Men 3.
Of course, with Ant-Man And The Wasp out this
year as well, I couldn't help but also think
of Giant-Man.
Jack-Jack's ability to teleport is an incredibly
useful one that first manifested in Jack-Jack
Attack.
This is the first power he ever displayed
and happened just after Kari put on some classical
music by Mozart.
The Parr family had always assumed Jack-Jack
was normal.
But just after Kari puts on some Mozart, Jack-Jack
seems to perk up and his eyes dilate and in
the next few seconds his powers kick into
action.
It seems it was Mozart that unlocked Jack-Jack's
latent superpowers because, as Kari says to
Helen,
"I also brought Mozart to play while he sleeps
because leading experts say Mozart makes babies
smarter."
Phasing through solid objects like walls and
windows is another incredibly useful skill
as it means Jack-Jack isn't really constrained
by any physical boundaries.
Kari witnessed this to hilarious effect in
Jack-Jack Attack and we also see him use it
in Incredibles 2.
Not only can Jack-Jack teleport between physical
locations, but he can also travel to other
dimensions and once there he can still even
communicate with our own dimension.
"Cookie!
Cha cha want a cookie?!"
"Nam nam cookie!"
"Cha cha want num num?"
By the way, the other dimension scene is a
fantastic easter egg to the classic horror
movie Poltergeist which I talk more about
in my easter eggs video.
There's a link for that at the end of this
video and in the video description.
We first get a taste of Jack-Jack's telekinetic
powers when, during the raccoon scene, he
uses his mind to raise the trash can lid off
the floor.
And it's Jack-Jack who ultimately breaks the
hypnotic spell cast on Elastigirl when he
telekinetically removes her googles.
Jack-Jack's telekinesis is a new ability that
we see for the first time in the sequel and
this power's been wielded by some of the most
powerful heroes on screen.
Think Professor X and Jean Grey from the X-Men
and Eleven from Stranger Things.
Jack-Jack's seventeen powers are all fantastic,
so deciding on my favourite was tough, but
his laser vision and how he uses it in the
raccoon scene is pretty amazing.
We did see the laser eyes for the first time
in Jack-Jack Attack where Kari used a hand-mirror
to deflect the rays, however, one of the funniest
moments in Incredibles 2 has to be when Bob
turns Jack-Jack into a kind of baby laser
gun.
Now, what your three favourite Jack-Jack powers?
And what would you like to see him do if there's
another sequel?
Let me know what you think and don't forget
to subscribe and turn on notifications to
enter my Incredibles giveaway.
Tap the link here to watch the top 30 easter
eggs you missed in Incredibles 2 or check
out my full Pixar playlist.
If you enjoyed this, a like is really appreciated
and you can tweet me at Jan_Gilbert.
New Incredibles 2 videos are on the way plus
Jurassic World 2 next week.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.